hey guys i'm off the grid for august and
here's joe rogan making some sense and
maybe it'll trickle up to the mainstream
you never know
the us is in a recession at the moment
but it's not allowed to be called a
recession
well the government's trying to not call
it a recession but it's wikipedia
article
got changed you see this really
oh dude no so they redefined recession
yep so recession used to be two
consecutive quarters of negative gdp
growth
right
not anymore not on wikipedia when was
this jamie get the get the wikipedia
thing up because this is wild how long
ago they changed it this weekend oh god
uh i saw it got well i saw it got locked
because people were [ __ ] with it is
what i read but i don't know how much of
that was but this is the definition when
you type in google which is the same
thing
so a period of temporary economic
decline during which trade and
industrial activity are reduced
generally identified by a fall in gdp in
two successive quarters so
in google it's still the same in
wikipedia let's look at what it what it
says
recession is a business cycle
contraction where there's a general
decline in economic activity recessions
generally occur
when there is a widespread spread drop
in spending and or
an adverse
demand shock this may
be triggered by various events such as
financial crisis and external trade
shock and adverse supply shock
bursting okay here it is a recession is
defined by the national bureau of
economic research has a significant
decline in economic activity spread
across the market lasting more than a
few months
normally visible in real gdp real income
employment industrial production and
wholesale retail sales
so
in the uk it's the in the uk it's
defined as that in uk it's defined as a
negative economic growth for two
consecutive quarters so that
so that's what's changed that the united
states used to define it as two
consecutive quarters and now we don't
anymore and people have pulled it up on
the archive so a bunch of advisors
economic advisers have got quotes of
them saying what a recession is
especially when donald trump was in
office there is a recession that's
coming negative gdp growth for two
consecutive quarters right and then this
weekend people are asking them are we in
a recession because the second quarter
uh economics just came out and it's
0.9 decline again have you seen the
white house press secretary
define
the economy as being strong and the best
economy we've had in over a decade have
you seen her do that no it's hilarious
it's like the wildest gas lighting
because she's doing all of these
political hand maneuvers that people do
you know those moves that people do with
their hands when they're talking and
they're trying to display like
confidence and control and there's like
it's it's literally like political
pantomiming the bizarre thing about the
uh recession situation is the fact that
it doesn't matter what you call it right
you can call it [ __ ] paradise if you
want but it's still [ __ ] right like all
of the criteria of what's happening yes
indicates a recession yes and the reason
obviously is you've got midterms coming
up and you need to make sure that is in
a recession is not something that can be
thrown at the democrats yes right it's a
protectionist strategy
yes so no don't use that word well it's
not it's not because it's not defined in
that way right that's not the accepted
definition right but it was until very
very very recently that's wild well
that's gaslighting that and just that
alone you know is
people would think that it's trivial
because they are
talking about
this economic downturn
but it's not trivial because we've
always used that term recession and
we've always used that term to define
whether or not the economic policies
that are currently in place and whether
or not the management the government has
done a good job of making sure that the
economy stays in a good place that's
they definitely haven't done that so in
order to escape that in you know that
sort of distinction they're literally
changing the definition which is
terrible and it should be pushed back
against in a big way it should it should
be something that people get angry about
like hey you're [ __ ] with definitions
in order to pretend that you're doing a
good job well the reason that you attach
a sequence of letters to
something right is to represent what
that thing is you don't change reality
by changing what those words actually
mean right
but if you can't control the economy you
might as well just control the language
and hope for the best god
what a bunch of weasels